what's up everyone Matthew and Sina here
and today we are reviewing your
portfolios and I'm joined by patrulla
Veron tychicus and in the last episode
of the portfolio reviews we went deep on
three particular portfolios so one of
the clear takeaways that we found in
episode 1 is that you have to have very
focused and clear context for your work
that you're presenting to other people
so that when somebody is looking at your
work it's guided for them and they
understand the decisions that you made
your role in it and how you've solved a
particular design challenge so I know we
went in depth on a couple of portfolios
in the last episode today my goal is to
take that information and go a little
bit more lightning speed and cover a lot
more portfolios alright so now let's
look at Joel hos portfolio and Joel
wants to get a job and a little context
on him a communication designer student
based in Singapore specializing in
branding and typography often
integrating storytelling throughout his
body of work ranging from publications
corporate identities photography and
illustrations sounds so interesting
already very interesting and also very
broad so we'll see that my assumption is
this person has a jack-of-all-trades
love it
okay I really love starting out with a
statement so this gives me super good
context hey Joel yes Joel is this
amorphous visual communicator who
subscribes did the belief that design
should be purposeful functional and
relevant to its original intention
that's cool I also like that I like
having a statement first just because
it's a nice way to frame the rest of the
experience that you're gonna see on the
website big bold love it so I'm gonna
start on the top left here and this
project is called world at your street
2019 so it has a little context here
upfront I'll just read the first
paragraph the Singapore Singapore Street
festival is a non-profit social and
community project founded in 2002
SSF is a yearly event offering the
opportunity for you to showcase their
diverse talents skills and capabilities
in performing arts visual arts urban
sports technology and design the brief
was to create a thematic or graphic
identity for its 18th edition so I'll
just read a little more actually I do
want context that was pretty well
written world at your street ways 2019
aims to foster a community spirit
between the local and global
practitioners ways 2019 provides an
avenue for emerging youth talent in asia
region in the asia region to achieve new
grounds friendship works and leaders
through the power of spirit and
collaboration okay so this is great
because I'm getting the context of who
the audience is why the audience would
care where it's gonna be seen so this is
really good because if I'm gonna
evaluate this work I now really know so
much more about what his goals are mm-hm
for me I feel really empowered now to
see the work in a way that would be I
thought a thin t'k and I can tell
whether he solved the problem well
because I know more about what the
problem was mm-hmm all day your shoot so
I'm guessing this is you there poster a
cover for something have to date there
so already I get the sense that it's
very eclectic right because the whole
idea is to bring communities together he
could give us some captions that let us
know that this is a poster these this is
probably a brochure he's flatten the
brochure or so it's hard for us to tell
its relationship to you know how large
it is if he had a hand in there or
anything to give me scale it would be
great mm-hmm
oh these wristbands yeah for some people
I wouldn't matter it took me a while to
just register what that was
but that's pretty cool but you're right
this would be better if it was just
right on the hand much nicer mock-up and
that tickets I'll date your stream so
this is cool I like seeing all the brand
applications these buttons are beautiful
yeah I love that I love that iteration
of it I'm guessing that's the website
and then other pages then more the
specific pages he's got what is referred
to as a transmedia design problem where
he's taking a particular brand and he's
moving that brand into different media
types whether it's a wristband or
brochure or website it's really helpful
to know what he's trying to do that's
different on the poster than on the
website right so if you can clue us in
then we understand your on your
knowledge about what different media can
do or does for a particular branding
project right actually that was I was
thinking the same thing and where I was
most delighted when I called out the
buttons yeah I was like well the buttons
are so beautiful and that's because of
the interpretation of how the brand is
applied in this situation it looks very
uniquely different compared to the rest
whereas I think if we look at earlier on
once we saw the initial poster or cover
art it almost feel like these are just
cut down right into the same thing
instead of a reinterpretation of how it
should be applied the wristbands are
probably a pretty good one but even that
like we could have just used bold
patterns across these instead of
breaking it up with so many of the lines
it took another one of his projects you
see how how it's going well let's see
what this one is happening doesn't
barcode yeah it says gay Lang your
passport to one of the least touristy
areas of Singapore and irrelevant guide
to all things gay lang presents
residence checklist of all you need to
know about the country's most
intoxicating area oh that's interesting
I'm I'm already intrigued yes I love the
description the description is enticing
I don't know anything about this area at
all and I'm ready right so copywriting
is a very important tool that I feel all
designers need to pick up even if it's
just a little bit because writing
personally has helped me quite a bit in
articulating my ideas so let's get into
this says under slick design cover this
pocket size travel Bible unearths the
hippest in the nightlife the buzziest
hotel and the coolest retail the most
influential makan places the best in
local design and the contemporary
architecture that defines scaling they
are rigorous rigorously research and
curated by an extensive network of one
student residence okay this is super
cool because this tells me that this
designer has immersed himself in a
community and he is now reinterpreting
what he sees in a community and I can't
tell you how important it is for
designers not to stay in this bubble but
to go and see how they are observing the
world and recontextualizing that in the
work they do so this is I I'm happy
about this person mm-hmm just by the
nature of the self-initiated problem to
solve I love the title that and
irrelevant I tell all things gala nice
beautiful typography year I like the
color typography and layout on this one
I think is showing me better typographic
skills than the world festival
yeah I mean there's still little things
that nobody need to be improved like if
we look at the letting year and the N
and the T on infrastructure they're kind
of colliding in a usual way on this
little friction point right there
infrastructure little things but you're
right it is better than the first
example I love these maps
these are nice little Henry it would be
helpful if Joel would have had with some
some call-outs because we can't actually
really read this and there's there's he
set it up that we're gonna be delighted
about some of these funny unimportant
things mm-hmm I can't I can't read any
of that right so I'm not he's set up
something
he's not yet we've gone through what
like seven pages and we haven't it isn't
really delivered correct okay sir I mean
I like I like the variance of spreads
like this is a fun editorial project
where you get to break down and make use
of image and type at different scales
and sizes and contrast yeah and I think
there are more opportunities to play
with a type in photo where in earlier
frames like you have these fun full
spread type set type sets but I think
you can play more with what's on the
left side versus what's on the right
side so I don't know what let's get well
I see let's get thorny because this is a
durian fruit fruit which is thanks
supposedly but you know there could be
some copywriting there that's really
funny about the smell of durian fruit we
kind of move on yeah let's move on let's
look at the Joel this is really good I
think there's a few missed opportunities
that that I'd like you to consider a
more clear consistent payoff but I
really like what you're doing it yeah I
think this is it I hope you get what
you're looking for because I think
things are coming along really well for
you yeah Joel I just want to say I want
to commend you because I think your
copywriting is pretty good and I think
that is a skill that most designers do
need to pick up because it does help
contextualize the work and it gives us a
very clear flavor right away before we
even see any of the work of what to
expect and kind of puts a delightful
moment up front for us as we're getting
into these it's your superpower Joel all
right let's look at the next portfolio
we have Marie addameer Marie's goal is
to get freelance work I am a graphic
designer who recently moved to New York
I have been in the business for eight
years and I'm currently working full
time as a package designer my web site
showcases branding and packaging
projects with focus on typography I
would like to get more freelance work
within those same areas so I'm wondering
if my site conveys that message across
as a whole
anything that I should add to stand out
well first of all Marie just being able
to ask us that question that was super
helpful it's great when you're looking
for a feedback is to let the other
person know what kind of feedback you're
looking for because I get this often all
the time where people will send me their
portfolio and say can you review my work
and then that's it
first of all you're asking too much time
of me and second of all you're asking me
a very big question and my usual
follow-up is well what do you want
feedback on what is your goals how do
you want me to look at this because I
can go all over the place and I could
end up focusing on something that you
don't want me to talk about so Marie
kudos to you for framing that's very
very tight so we know that you're in
branding and packaging and you love
typography so you want to make sure that
your portfolio is a reflection of that
so you can do more work in that area
okay so again we have this nice big
opening statement I'm a senior graphic
designer with focuses on brand identity
packaging typography in the digital
design I feel like we could probably
lose one of these maybe digital design I
don't know seems it's like I'd rather
have the focus on brand identity and
packaging and I don't know that you need
to go in on typography necessarily I
don't know if people are necessarily
looking at that as a particular skill
but what do you think I would leave it
in I think we did it
I think for what she says she wants
freelance work with design firms and
agencies I'm assuming that's what she
wants mm-hmm then there will have high
expectations of this so I'm interested
to see more typography to see if indeed
she's delivering on that right so let's
get into this first one mocha gourmet
doughnuts
a visual identity and packaging for a
gourmet doughnut shop incorporating
experimental typography for wall decor
so I'm guessing this is the mark that
she made mocha looks like a dipped
doughnut with some frosting on top which
is actually making me more hungry than
anything in terms of the letter forms on
this particular logo I think it's a
little bit jammed up when I squint my
eyes you know it's really hard to make
sense of the forms that I see so one
suggestion I would have is just to take
more advantage of the negative and
counter space in between the letter
forms here to make that a little bit
more legible but what I do like is that
it kind of feels like they feel like
Donuts I like the shape of it so there's
something a little bit fun about that
the contrast that I think that gourmet
doughnuts feels a little too stiff for
me stiff and clinical relative to this
because if we just had mocha by itself
that's actually pretty fun looking and
then this I feel like weighs it down the
gourmet doughnut but take a look at the
same things happening at the top mm-hmm
if we go back to her this that's what's
going on here she's got this sort of you
know typographic idea here and then this
gets super straight super fast so maybe
when she's talking about typography
she's talking about some logo type
mm-hmm okay but this in both instances
I'm noticing that this is fairly safe
but let's keep going yeah I'm not in
love with the type pairing there
I like the colors on this this is fun
they're almost complementary colors it
might be complementary colors actually
this is fun I like this stuff these
all-over prints you can see this as
wallpaper or the like the paper inside
of a donut donut box which would
actually be nice to see some of those
applications so as we scroll down I'm
hoping oh there we go
yeah there we go this I think this is
where the design seems to be coming
together more I'm not as fond of the
others but I do I'm really appreciating
the way this packaging application works
so you might want to move
that packaging application up yeah
because I you know you want to start
with a nice WoW element where you draw
somebody in with a very beautiful
saturated image or sexy imagery and then
you can get into the more rough stuff in
between as you build your case back up I
would consider probably cutting down
some of the examples and focusing on the
things that are really beautiful it's
just this nice packaging and I even like
this all over print somewhere okay let's
look at another bit okay let's look at
this very strong packaging nice imagery
up front beauty packaging introducing
three skincare lines targeting different
concerns for women on the facial areas
of the skin I think that's a 3d package
again it's so interesting because the
thumbnail was very beautiful and then
when I get here like I feel like this
one is very boring to start with like
these look more interesting to me than
the other one no this is such a
competitive market I would like to know
what she's trying to do that's gonna
differentiate this brand from others
because this does have a really strong
look I just want to know a little bit
more about the problems she's trying to
solve right so I get a little bit more
context there would be helpful so we
know what we're looking at I have a
feeling I'm not that familiar with this
brand but this is actually possibly an
existing packaging form if it's not
Marie if you're actually designing
packaging forms let us know that you do
that mm-hmm
because that's what they're that's a
quite a specialization within packaging
and it's really hard to do
so if you are doing the form design and
the typography it means a lot more to me
understanding those those capabilities
right that's right this context will
help you've given us three lines a black
one a white one and a red one and
nothing that tells me what the
differences are or why they're that way
or maybe these are options that you're
giving a client
mm-hmm and if that's the case I'd like
to know what they did okay you want to
just pick a random yeah I'm gonna go
dishing out all right let's take a look
at this one typographic recipe tea
towels with spiced bottles and
complimentary DIY scrapbook to jot down
new recipes so we can see that Marie
you've got that sort of more hand-drawn
and then when this secondary typography
comes in it's usually pretty
conservative mm-hmm but this is nice
this is nice to see some experimentation
some of them I'm more fond of than
others but I do get a sense of your
approach to typography forms here mm-hmm
I'm confused why we're going from here
to here what the relationship is right
so the the way you photographed it and
put it on here I'm I'm is causing me a
little confusion scale-wise mm-hmm
I think I'm starting to get it here so
this comes in a little package and these
little tea towels these things they have
printed on but again I think it's the
same thing that we saw earlier where
some of these more contextual beautiful
this could be posters right or they
could be spreads in a book right the
thing is we don't have the context until
we get further down I know you think
you've told us but because it's it a
little difficult concept I didn't really
understand it and I don't know what a
little while longer it's the same thing
for me so Marie I think even though
we've taken just a really quick look in
your portfolio I think because you've
done so much work more food and beverage
packaging that might be that you narrow
in on that when you're looking for some
of that freelance work because you've
done so much of it I'm still a little
iffy on some of the ways you're working
with these type forms there's some
expertise that I'm
I'm really wanting to see a little bit
more of and in regards to some of those
forms because they're interesting
they're expressive but they think
they've fundamentally got some some
problems that in execution right
it's just liking the refinement so if
we're looking at this let's look at her
logo right away so Marie
I like the playfulness of how the D and
the M are working together and then how
the this dot on the R is becoming the
dot of the highlight this is very fun
but then when we get to this gap this is
a really weird gap when we go from AI to
E and this negative space right here
does not feel resolved where everything
else feels very tight and then compact
and then you have this gap here word now
I don't know if this was meant to align
with the dot of the eye here below I'm
not quite sure but it's lacking
refinement and if we look at the curves
my suspicion if there's there's probably
one two three four five six points on
that curve that you drew an illustrator
this could easily be done in three
points so those are little things that I
could tell execution-wise just by
looking at this that could use some
refinement in the letter form so to
highlight the best things I think you're
really good at expressive typography and
exploring a lot of things I think just
going all in on the typography part and
refining the letter forms is something
that you can definitely improve on and
then what patrulla was saying earlier
the packaging is another area that can
you can have a lot of fun with and I
think with some of the photography
examples that we saw in there
seems like you're already exploring that
which is which is fine I think you could
go even further on those because coming
up with a really good packaging for a
product is the thing that makes it stand
out and that is very valuable to
potential employers
all right so shall we move on mm-hmm now
we are gonna look at Danielle dev martes
this person's goal is to get a job I'm
an Italian designer and I live in Italy
now I'm looking for a job I assume you
mean a job in Italy do you think I think
so okay so then the work might be
contextual to the Italian design
community yeah
okay so we land here and the first thing
that I get a sense of is that the
portfolio is a little all over the place
I see some character stuff right here in
the middle row I'm assuming these are
some kind of poster designs here in the
last three ones and then this top one
here seems more of like some kind of
digital imaging and then we got some
logo designs in the top right so it
feels like it's a little all over the
place for me right now
so Danielle you have a big missed
opportunity under this okay you're
Italian graphic designer
tell us more no no I really want to know
things I can hire you for right right
things that you specialize in maybe a
little bit about your background mm-hmm
so I go to this project look at me twice
double color exposure not much context
this is beautiful mm-hmm so I'm assuming
that you took the photographs for this
to do these double exposures see for me
it's like I don't mind seeing personal
work but when I land on here and I see
graphic designer my first assumption is
that you're gonna be really good at
layouts and typography that whatever
design then you get into and then I look
at this and it's all images hmm and so
there's already a huge disconnect and if
it were me and I'm looking to hire you I
would pass because it doesn't follow my
expectations but you have a lot of
opportunities here to give us more
context and how we're looking at the
work okay so I'm gonna click on this one
just because this image intrigues me so
poster collection volume 1 so again no
context other than that these are
posters but we don't know what they are
September 2018 poster collection so
these look more like self promotional
images or it's I guess various topics
NYC poster collection like these are
beautifully laid out I love the colors
in here I think these are pretty well
done
but I don't know what they're for so
it's really hard for me to gauge them
outside of just an aesthetic standpoint
so for me as somebody who's looking to
hire you if I'm looking to make
something in this style I'll probably
hire you for it but you know if I'm
looking to bring you on to solve
different client client projects and
client problems I wouldn't know how to
use you necessarily here because I don't
know understand what problem you're
solving here but visually they're very
intriguing they drew my eye in but
there's graphic designers that are
producing posters for events for
identification for communication right
I'm not feeling the communication part
of that is clear or there are artists
that are using graphic design as a
medium mhm
this feels like you're using a poster as
a medium for some of your artwork mhm
but I'm not finding a communication
going for it right so based on on what I
see I would probably hire you for a
stylistic photography mm-hmm so I think
it's totally fine to experiment with
stuff and to spread your wings in terms
of what you want to explore creatively
and artistically the challenge is me
being somebody who wants to hire you I
have no idea where your strengths are
and you know what it is I should hire
you for so that's something to consider
when you're thinking about the
empathetic side of of who's looking at
your portfolio
Danielle want a job or freelance work I
forget they want to get a job okay this
is a portfolio that would probably be
more effective getting freelance work
because you're basically showing
stylistic skills I don't know if I
necessarily agree with that I think if I
were looking at the best bet for
Danielle is to be a production artist
somewhere where everything's already
thought out beforehand and somebody's
just hiring this person mm-hmm to
execute the design so if that's not what
you're interested in
then I think the context part will
really really help because we're just
we're just looking at the work visually
now yeah we're totally guessing so I
think lots of good creative
here but have no idea on how to evaluate
it so just consider that Danielle when
you're revamping your portfolio and
you're putting it out there and you're
sending it to people that they have
clear context that what you do
that's move on so we're looking at
Roberto horoscope or ESCO and his goal
is to get freelance work hi I'm Roberto
I'm based out of Las Vegas and I'm a
full-time freelancer I mainly focus on
illustrations and also offer design work
such as logos I've been full-time since
2015 and most of my clients are in the
athletic and sports centric industries
with some variance in clientele my work
is vibrant and vector-based my goal is
to grow as an illustrator and work with
big clients and bigger budgets so this
one's a little bit outside of some of
the other ones where we're looking at
them mostly as a designer
this one's Roberto is more of an
illustrator so let's get into Roberto's
work well he just wants to continue
freelancing I guess okay stop here okay
I like Roberto I like this picture of
him I really just think it's got great
character and I like what he's saying
small studio bringing big ideas to life
this is really really fun thanks Roberto
this is delightful great first
impression and then he just gives a
quick summary about who he is who he's
worked for and I'm really happy that
he's telling me some of the clients and
projects he's worked on no this is this
is nice it's really clear fantastic okay
let's get into this and it's bold bold a
bold move to do that because many people
will start with the work and not the
person I'm hiring a person and to work
all right so as we scroll through this I
think it's reinforced what he called out
that he's all about illustration and I
could definitely see that there's tons
and tons of examples here mm-hmm of
these vector-based illustration so it's
and there's a lot of energy to the work
there's a particular style and approach
but that's fine because that's his style
and approach and hmm it's very bold I
think from the beginning on the way till
now it seems like it's quite consistent
in terms of how it's being presented so
this is very cool night raid Oni mask
night raid is a las vegas-based Street
tuner Street poet that's a typo right
there Street tuner club focus on
high-end cars and custom-built Japanese
import race cars they wanted the unique
design that reflected their style and
method of taking their Street tuner
culture mass came from the idea that
they want its members to be run like a
clan a group that draws the masks and
lives in the tuner culture I wanted to
make a more visceral pony mess that
really hit that note so this is fun I
love the details on this thing it looks
like this is a patch or some kind of
maybe a air freshener or something and I
like the story I think that context is
very nice in terms of understanding who
this is for because it feels quite
appropriate for this Street tuner
culture oh this is my favorite one this
recall that when it's embossed embossed
yeah yeah that's beautiful so you could
roll mm-hmm this is really fun unlike
the pizza gang aesthetics yeah they are
brand that focus on providing direct
one-on-one training to their clients
they reached out I needed a fun take on
their branding they wanted to be based
on their laid-back style of dealing with
clients and keep it fun so this super
cool right because you don't necessarily
think of pizza when you're thinking
about getting fit and working out but I
think it's very much like the Planet
Fitness approach where they don't judge
you in terms of the the gym culture
there I want you to see the organization
of Roberto's website Behance doesn't
offer this but so many website templates
do so I've scrolled down this whole
thing and then I get to see this again
so I don't have to scroll back up mm-hmm
I guess it's always always available to
me and I can I can see the depth and
depth and depth and depth of this so
these are super cool I think it's very
clear to me your style and some of the
things that you're very good at so that
me as a potential client if I'm looking
for this thing I could hire you straight
up for that so Roberta you mentioned
that you
to now work for larger current let's say
dues freelance work for a Nike or adidas
or or something like that
um I think if you were to transfer some
of these things onto more sports apparel
show more how this stuff might look in a
retail environment because it is looking
very small client like because that's
what you're doing what I want to do is
for you to look at how some of the
larger logos and brands are utilizing
not just an image but but that image and
its color scheme or form and maybe mock
up a few things that show bigger
applications and more widespread like
brand applications and they would want
to see your unique take on on apparel
logo applications right so if his goal
is do bigger brands and bigger budgets
you just have to paint that picture even
if you're not even there yet with
existing work if you mock it up in a
very particular way it will feel bigger
than it originally was intended versus
just the isolated illustration that you
have here and you can you can take it
out of just decorative reason but you
can do a sub-brand of of Nike okay with
your samurai series and you know sort of
create a sub sub brand label and that is
for a particular kind of athlete mm-hmm
so as a fictitious project your
suggested because there's a very quaint
Ness and small sort of community based
feeling that this has so if you're
looking out for the future to be broader
then this needs to I need some a few
examples and keep them in the first row
so people don't miss them mm-hmm cool
let's go thanks Roberto so am a ref key
wants to get freelance work and this
person says I'm a freelance graphic
designer with six years experience I do
branding and web design
let's take a look Mishka hello my name
is May I'm a designer based in Cairo so
let's go into branding okay so you're
just on first glance these are nice big
images I like these because it allows a
lot of the thumbnails to stand out
they're all pretty minimal or very bold
and they're nice to play off the top
okay if except after successful three
years in the Egyptian market ethics
ethics are I fix needed a rebrand that
communicated its growth and maturity we
wanted to rebrand to feel friendly and
clean
so why rebrand logo only focused on the
eye fixer I fix now is more than just
that logo wasn't simple enough logo had
many colors logo had small details local
wasn't serious enough logo needed a
refresh to convey growth there's a typo
and a logo that conveyed that I don't
know what I fix or I fix her is so
please have more empathy to me as
someone who is unaware you're talking
even in these after three years in the
Egyptian market where are they going
are they going out of the Egyptian
market okay what do they do this is as
the term that that Mathew used all over
the place this is this is all over the
place mmm-hmm and an analyst in this
typos really really big problem is the
truest pet piece we know that there's a
particular familiarity that this has it
looks a lot like a lot of the city
banker yeah city bank so a lot of times
when I'm producing a logo I will
actually do a Google reverse image
search to see what is out there that
looks just like this so I would really
suggest doing that because otherwise
there may be designers that have done
this before and it if you're going to
sell certainly if you're going to sell
the stuff to a client they they want it
to have more
of a distinctive feel because it really
is very referent referential to logos
that exist out there yeah for me like I
don't mind if logos look similar or
alike at all like that doesn't bother me
what what I would like to know is the
thinking behind it so how did you arrive
at this and why are we why did you
arrive at this final mark and I think
you wanted to incorporate some kind of
smile or a face and they're based off of
some of the slides but it still doesn't
give me any insight as to what the
company does and why there's a smile or
face involved to begin with I still
don't know what this I fix it even with
this ad yeah I can't figure it out hmm I
don't think we need to spend that much
more time on this I think the mock-ups
and the work look pretty decent what's
challenging is just understanding what
the heck we're looking at because these
applications are actually pretty nice I
love the bold colors like those are fun
but again it's very hard to evaluate
because we don't know what we're looking
at yeah this feels may a bit
disorganized to me and not giving giving
me information I don't need mm-hmm and
not giving me information I do need
mm-hmm all right let's stop there now
we're gonna look at the portfolio of
Jillian Wang and the goal is to get a
job I said Jesus should be junior
graphic designer yeah all right I wish
there was a lot more context there you
have an opportunity to fill this up okay
Jillian Wang so first impression just
landing on the site it's nice and clean
the images pop out down here I'm very
intrigued by this pasta packaging so I
want to click in here just because it's
an interesting image very cool packaging
created for Grandma Marjorie who is a
member of the knitting club where her
pasta became famous this story has
become the inspiration behind the design
concept so this is cool this is um is it
knitting or stitching I forget what you
call this particular needlepoint
needlepoint okay needlepoint and then
that it's reoccurring in all the design
aspects so that's pretty fun this is oh
look at how nice
this is REM hmm I love the details in
here I don't know about the word
spaghetti but I'm on Mars
I like how quirky spaghetti it feels
like somebody's got a sloppy handwriting
a little bit but it makes it feel so
personal that this has a nice charm to
it
yeah it's simply presented I get the
context so I I love the immediacy of
this one because in some instances
Matthew and I have had to go deep deep
deep deep just to figure something out
mm-hmm so far so good yeah very clear it
has a nice of visceral reaction from
both of us so that's something that's
quite nice on a surface level so let's
jump into this chop chop chop chop a
brochure was designed for a big kitchen
master class I promote cooking to food
lovers and to inspire them to improve
their cooking skills chop chop so I'm
assuming there's something immediate
about it maybe it's a quick class that's
why it's called chop chop always
dangerous just use typography this way
into the gutter yeah yeah just because
depending on how it's ditch in
production you might actually lose a lot
of this and it's gonna fold over it's
rarely aligned right tolerances are such
right so this is easy for a mock-up but
very difficult to actually execute for a
lot of these I like the balance of the
typography and these spreads I do like
the colors but I don't know if they're
gonna work together very well cuz even
on this if I squint my eyes the contrast
level between the values of these two
colors here they're very close
especially on this pink on blue so it's
very hard to read I think there are a
lot of opportunities where you could
really play with the typography and what
I was expecting from seeing the front
here where chop is literally chopped
here that I was gonna see more fun
explorations of typography there in the
recipes or describing what the courses
are about just having a little bit more
fun with it and I can see the numbers
are starting to get cropped off here on
the one and two I think there's
opportunities to go even deeper on that
let's go into her photography
Photography okay so this another tab
here and I I don't want to quickly read
her about statement the reason I want to
do that is because if I'm looking for to
hire a junior designer I'm looking to
really understand the broadness or
capabilities mm-hmm so there's a certain
way I'm I'm I'm viewing this thing that
might be different than someone who's
just looking for a freelance job mm-hmm
okay so photography's not bringing up
ever anything yeah don't take a deep
problem yeah I don't know if people will
click off like that if if you have any
any password-protected stuff if you have
any you know project to come people will
give up at that moment so most people
will be gone unfortunately on the site
so now we're in the About section huh
don't work together she's currently
available for work opportunities let's
see what happens again I mentioned in a
previous episode but I don't like these
contact forms if I bring on a junior
designer oh if I am an agency or a
design firm I'm looking for a lot of
times a broader capable capability if
I'm a freelancer a lot of times I'm
looking for a specialized skill hmm
interesting I think and if I'm in-house
I'm looking for a little bit more
understanding of of what you do in a
particular industry like oh we're in
food we're in a lot in food and beverage
so this is and we're in gourmet
artisanal cooking stuff so there are
then these two things are gonna mean a
lot to me
right so she has some level of expertise
and interest in an area that we do a lot
of work in right yeah I mean I'm I'm
with you to a degree like I agree that
seeing a breadth of work is interesting
as long as it's consistently applied so
forward transmedia designers which is a
term that's out there being able to
apply the same brand or same design
solution across different applications
is the thing that I'm looking for but
for the most part regardless if it's
freelance or for staff I'm still looking
for somebody that's highly focused and
does a couple of things very well
depending on what I'm looking for them
so if I we do a lot of brand identity
here looking somebody who does identity
systems have some examples of that but
and other things for instance like
posters and stuff maybe their typography
is just really good because those are
overlapping skills that I'm looking for
mm-hmm all right Gillian so for your
work here I think this pasta packaging
thing really stands out it has a nice
visceral feeling
I think this chop chop also has
opportunities to be really fun I would
actually like to just see more of these
types of projects on your portfolio
because I think you might have you might
have a future for yourself doing these
fun packaging types of examples because
this honestly my favorite one from you
so more of that more of these things
that with a lot of character because I
think you have a future there all right
let's go to the next one up next
Francesco that puppies Stella that
Estella goal is to get a job I live in
Italy near Venice and I study graphic
design and communication so that leads
me to believe this person is still in
school at the moment is probably on
their way to exit first impressions any
I'm intrigued by this work mm-hmm I'm
I'm optimistic all right do you want to
click in on one of these no let's do it
for the first or the second okay we have
self car laughter okay so this is a
different kind of presentation okay
scrolling left to right oh man
unfortunately I think a lot of this is
in Italian so we could only assume what
we're reading here I'm assuming this is
a museum what do you think some kind of
a exhibit yes right because I said these
are tickets for this exhibit
mm-hmm which I always love these types
of projects museum projects are always
super fun and I love seeing them because
they can be so creative so fun
especially if it's an open project I
know an Arts Center they they do this
project for one of the classes where you
can invent your own Museum and invent
everything about it including the
curation Francesca I really like your
work I really like how you present
the breath of this project I am very
interested in branding projects that are
across multiple media types and I think
it's just terrific to see the brochure
the environmental eye
I like your process I think for for
student or young designer at work this
is a this is a really a really helpful
good solution in this mark it's a little
goofy because it's such a very
traditional image and you've put it in
this funny almost Memphis II context
mm-hmm I'm a little iffy on the craft of
those waves mm-hmm but that's probably
my biggest criticism of this particular
project right so it's in the details
they can use some refinements the
overall breadth is the impress
impressive part about this I just also
just appreciate how you're presenting it
to us let's jump into the slasher films
okay bold for me something caught my eye
it's loading it's loading and it could
be because this is from across the world
so the content delivery is okay it's an
Italian so I assume it's a film
production company slash films yeah
maybe
yeah production company so Francesca it
doesn't matter if it's just in Italian
if you're looking for work in Italy but
if you are looking for work outside of
Italy then you may want to put it in
different languages mm-hmm whether
that's whether you want to work in
France or right you just have to
sexualize it to the market that you're
applying for so this is super cool
that's part of the identity system slash
films is a dynamic identity system so it
has this kind of almost looks like a
folded french fry type of thing it's
it's moving dynamically and it looks
like it's this part is actually modular
and men double so what I like about the
presentation here that I feel like some
other designers can learn from is that
even though we don't understand the
words that are on the screen I think the
sequence of images are very clear to me
and how I'm understanding the story here
so yeah don't I agree
philately don't undervalue the
importance of how you sequence your
images because here I can see that this
is a dynamic identity system and then
right after I see an application for how
that lives these two posters right here
you can see now you have this dynamic
mark that's kind of bending for these
applications
I think we've mentioned this before but
when you look at a brand and you look at
the different applications it shouldn't
feel the same across the board it
shouldn't feel like you just took one
key image and tried to wrap it around
ten different things you should really
be thinking about how do you take these
graphic elements and reapply it that's
appropriate to the brand application and
then feel free to explore with materials
how it's actually wrapping around and
how much or how little of the brand you
actually see in there so Francesco I is
showing us the famous people photography
yeah and I like this very much I like
seeing your eye for photography develop
and I like seeing that your
documentation of life even though it's
separated out from your work I like that
I we don't have time to go into every
single project on your homepage but one
of the things that I love is to see your
own photography in your own work so I'm
you you might want to you might think
you're presenting it right in two
separate hats you know here's one I have
a photographer here's an I'm a designer
but if you can put that one hat on and
show me how you are amazing graphic
designer using your own photography then
I value you more right I really we don't
have to hire an outside photographer we
can work with you and we can have that
image be something that you're really
proud of right we're all proud I would
say to that point too because if you
have control over the photography if you
have your own skills and you're able to
take those photos and apply it and
combine it with your design it shows me
another layer of thinking that other
people do not
so some designers are quite limited in
of what their skillset is usually
they're there at the mercy of whatever
content is given to them but in this
case if you're able to generate an art
direct the photography ahead of time and
you implement that into your designs it
shows me that you're thinking from a
very high level of how all of these
things are going to come together I like
what you're doing here you're giving me
this really very broad there's a lot of
work in this website and it sounds still
in school I think so this is really
impressive for someone who is a young
designer still in school there's just a
lot of experimentation I can I can feel
your desire to learn and that's one of
the most important attributes if I'm
gonna work with it with a junior
designer and hire you right so yet some
people don't think about this as well
but like I was mentioning earlier it's
uh all of these things add up it's all a
compound effect of what your about page
says what your landing page looks like
how you choose to sequence the images
what copy you choose to put with imagery
all of these things add up and I think
what patrulla is saying here at the end
what she gets is a sense of your spirit
of exploration as a totality of showing
this wide breadth of work but I like
that when we landed on there
I knew this person was a designer first
and then I got to explore and go out
because I was a little bit more
interested and intrigued to to read more
about it and you know this is all
separated out in photography and other
sections okay cool
your to work Francesco I think that's it
for that that's it yeah I think that's
it for the for the recap all right
everyone well I hope you got some value
out of this episode I want to first
thank my guests patrulla from Tychus for
joining me today and sharing her
insights and I think you guys got some
good tidbits from different sides of the
aisle here to understand how you can
improve your portfolio's alright guys
now it's time for our wrap-up if you've
seen episode one you know that there was
a bunch of hurdles that we already went
over last time so if you haven't seen it
make sure you go check out part one now
so if there's one key takeaway from
today's episode after reviewing all of
your work is
you need to clearly set expectations
then deliver on that in your bio in your
work and how you talk about how you've
arrived at your creative solution this
is positioning this is the space that
you occupy in somebody's mind when
they're looking at your work so if you
say you're a designer that does brand
identities for food and beverage but
then you follow up and show photography
or illustrations then there's a big
mismatch and a big gap and me as the
viewer who's evaluating I don't know how
to place you but if you claim a certain
expertise or Lane and then you deliver
on that with very clear presentations of
your portfolios how you speak about
yourself that case study the bio section
of the website pretty much everything
that points to who you are and what
makes you unique and the work that you
do these are ways to over-deliver on how
your position and how you're different
than all the other designers in the
market this is your way of standing out
in the marketplace when a client is
looking to hire you or a potential
employer is looking to bring somebody on
staff I hope you enjoyed this episode we
have a ton more videos on portfolios
like the four tips you can do to improve
your portfolio and part one of this
series go check those out also let us
know what your liking and what your key
takeaways were from this episode leave
us a timestamp comment below so we can
make more content like this specifically
for you we'll see you all in the future
[Music]